[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all the Royals I call it there's other
Royals come on come on over here come on
over
listen girls I put on my flats to the B
give you good tonight but I took it off
my heels there you go
I feel real good and I'm joining in I'm
turning in okay okay we were just
talking about the fact that you made it
all the way through the song on at the
very end I saw the tears coming maybe it
was sweat I mean it was very emotional
going to be honest I don't know what
happened I mean I'm sure cuz it's I've
been like sort of just keeping them
right here so I'm sure it happened if
you saw it happened thought I saw it but
maybe I was wrong but it made for a very
beautiful moment how did it feel
I mean because you know everybody's
talking about this being your moment
where we get to hear you sing live and
you killed it thank you thank you I'm
gonna say but yeah I mean it's super
exciting to be these incredible artists
- I am fans like I'm a true fan of all
what I mean
it's super cool to like look to your
left and your right you're like yeah so
it's it's really exciting for me Lauren
actually said that you put your right
before you were about to throw up
you're about like okay maybe bad you're
gonna throw up
no no no I was just hot yeah I don't do
the throw-up thing not nervous at all no
you know it's just really sort of like
centering it and being present and
grounding yourself
yeah what you guys think like was it
like this is like crazy I mean you guys
knocked out of the park I mean all y'all
like to be up there before I'm like
trying not to cry so I'm a little quiet
we were both just as inspired doing the
performances I'm sure people were
watching it does this mean that
everybody here has a guest spot on this
is a fabulous casting don't you think I
mean why not right why not all the girls
on the show no pressure
I don't even write it you can handle
that that's what I'll do for sure yeah
we're solving a debate here do you know
who said the prayer right before you
went on well no because there was there
are a couple of prayers yeah
yeah absolutely Mikey it was Carrie
right before the department you know I
was upstage so Carrie was Mickey now
wouldn't you like a great a great
performance okay great I've got it came
across the everybody was like loving the
moment it's really exciting really happy
you're gonna have a country music album
come on now music give any secrets about
that this is us as well yeah I'm gonna
do it
yeah I want to keep my job so you can
tell us anything nothing very generous
yeah I'm every you know there is a blue
man group here in Vegas
could we be like a blue woman growth
here no we're the six trees Carrie's not
here but we're the sixth string yeah
we're already on it
my dress was one room into a - I think
you guys kill the Blue Man Group but I
love them
like that would kind of be hard to get
off at the end of the night right
[Music]